well for afghanistan's women and girls
the return of the taliban means fear and
uncertainty
since the extremists were ousted 20
years ago women have taken on more
prominent roles in afghan society in
politics of women were guaranteed more
than a quarter of parliamentary seats
several even held ministerial posts like
saraya dalil who served as minister of
public health and was later named the
country's permanent representative to
the u.n
women also made an impact on the
security forces by joining the police in
the army with some rising through the
ranks like brigadier general shatool
muhammad zai muhammad zai the number of
women and girls receiving an education
also increased significantly the taliban
having long prohibited schooling for
girls over the age of 10.
now around a fifth of all university
students are women
so under the taliban access to even
basic health care was restricted for
women so a lot has changed in the last
two decades and now many fear
afghanistan's women will once again be
stripped of their rights
well hosnet jalil is a former deputy
minister of women's affairs and former
deputy minister of interior affairs in
the afghan government
welcome to dw
how are you feeling as you watch the
news and speak to colleagues and family
at home
thank you so much for having me
uh
how do i feel is something else and how
would i i would say uh foresee the
future for all of us is something else
i would say whatever we worked for
we built
and we built with our own hands
the facilitation and the support of the
international community for the last 20
years not just for ourselves but for for
the
future of our little kids and the
generations to come that's lost
that's gone
um i would say we have had just a
20 years like 20 years of trial between
one uh i would say taliban ruling regime
and they did the second version of
taliban's ruling regime
and sometimes i would say that is the
very maybe the very emotional version of
me saying this sometimes i would say if
we were supposed to hand over everything
so quickly and if we were supposed to be
left behind in the middle of nowhere to
be left in the middle of nowhere all of
a sudden i wish we hadn't started this i
mean this war
we'd start the war we sacrifice our
lives we do compromise i would say uh
everything for a better future but if
there was not a future why did we start
it right so when the talent happened in
2001 why we have been invited to to join
a war
so when the the the taliban this time
say that they will respect women's
rights within the framework of islamic
law
clearly
you don't believe that
i don't buy it for a couple of facts
i have spent my childhood during taliban
regime i fought with them after the
collapse of taliban regime i fought with
them for 20 years for good cause for a
legitimate cause
uh i've lived with them
in a district of afghanistan so i would
say i don't buy it for a couple of facts
first
when they have been asked last year when
they've been doing the peace deal with
the u.s
they've been asked what do you mean with
the
flexibility when it comes to women's
rights they are like according to
islamic rules
islamic rules was applied or sharia law
was applied during their own regime as
well and sharia law for them meant lack
of access to education restricted access
to health services no access to justice
no shelter no food security no
employment literally nothing
so when they've been asked what do you
mean by sharia law they've been stuck
and they have not been able to give us
give us the details the detailed
information plus
right now i am in touch with my um i
would say afghans on the ground with my
family on the ground
and they're like okay uh they've allowed
the health service providers the women
in the health sector they've allowed
them to uh to to start working again
or to rejoin the new ruling regime but
that's not the change of policy why do
we try to fantasize that taliban has
changed just because they are allowing
women to work in the health sector my
mom was a medical doctor and she was
allowed to work during taliban regime as
a gynecologist for the woman but that's
not also again that's not part of what
we call it again for the last 20 years
i would say presence in the technology
woman's presence in media women's
presence in sports women's presence and
so many other sectors and lastly women's
presence in the security sector that is
our achievement but they have already
started
making women to step down from their
post the first thing they did with the
taking with the takeover of the national
tv they changed the anchor a very
professionally trained woman
they changed it
so why do we fantasize that taliban has
changed and their policies for women has
changed no it's not changed although
they are under pressure uh made that
they might feel under pressure because
of the international community because
they're still having their two eyes but
i'm afraid that the day that afghanistan
would be forgotten once again and it
becomes irrelevant and no one would be
interested to
watch the news or to to read the news
about afghanistan
that is the worst day and that is when
taliban would give us
the real i would say faith and so just
just following on from that and going
back to what you said before you you
said given that the the the speed of the
american and the nato withdrawal just
effectively just scrambling out of
afghanistan
you you said that perhaps it would have
been better had the had these changes
not happened if they were to leave so
quickly well
now we have uh the us and and britain
and 18 other countries um releasing this
letter uh expressing concern about
afghan women's rights to education a
work and freedom of movement how do you
how do you view of that letter and those
sentiments from from those people who
you seem to feel left you so badly in
the lurch
let me just be clear on one thing
because whenever we speak of the very
irresponsible withdrawal we are held
accountable for the miseries we go
through yes i do take as as part of the
afghan i would say nation and as part of
the afghan government who has served
until the uh until uh i would say
the last two months
i mean i i i left my job two months ago
so i have served until june i do hold
myself responsible and accountable for
the miseries we go but i do share the
responsibility with our international
allies so i would say we have not been
expecting a lifelong presence of the
international troops or the
international support but we have been
expecting a much better responsible i
would say withdrawal
and it's like for me it's like we just
want to get rid of afghanistan which is
not fair it's not fair we've been
partnered
for shared cause although our interests
and cause might have been different at
some point but it has been shared big
time
it has been shared big time because they
have been defeating international
terrorist terrorist groups in my home
and they just to make sure that they
don't reach to their doors as well so
that was the commitment but i'm really
happy when the countries again they're
saying like okay we are concerned about
it because the u.s president just a few
days ago he mentioned that i don't care
about the woman's right of afghanistan
i've never been there
i i don't care about the minorities
right i've not been there for for that
was not my cause right i understand that
was my cause but we had so many other
shared values we have so many other
shared causes so i would say it makes me
happy if they again express their
concerns as far as they mean it as far
as that is not to make the
international community the individuals
across the globe who believes in
humanity
i i i
i really hope that they don't try to
make them calm down all right hosni
jalil former afghan government minister
thank you so much
thank you so much for having me